do you think I pulled off red hair in
college yeah John that's a lie hi I'm
David Clyde and I am Wesley clutch and
together with Acolytes Brothers and
Karen and I'm Connie we're twins and
today we're taking a lie detector test
I'm not nervous about taking this test I
believe I know everything about this guy
so I tried to come up with some
questions that it really maybe bring out
his dark side we'll say yes I am nervous
for today I have a lot of Secrets this
is already revealed too much I'm not
really nervous I'm just that I'm more
excited I feel like I already know some
of the answers to these questions I just
want it on tape we're really like honest
with each other we don't have a lot of
secrets from each other I mean I just
like said we don't have a lot of secrets
from each other are you about to prove
me wrong no oh that doesn't seem like a
lie at all I'm John I'm a polygraph
examiner we're gonna be reading
microscopic changes to their blood sweat
and breathing as they answer yes or no
questions
so take the jacket off read right
through oh really
mm-hmm probably high reads already going
I've got some questions here most of
these I've never asked before I'm really
excited to find out the answers I'm a
really big like goody two-shoes so like
this scenario is nothing I ever wanted
to be involved in perfect all right
let's go
how do you think our mom loves more you
or me you that's a lie have you ever
liked a guy I liked no I'm not that
surprised but it's good to know for sure
thank you John
do you think that you're more attractive
to women than I am for sure yes that's
true do you think that you are the good
twin no I think my name is Connie and
Connie Bereza
come on cause you'd do you think you lie
more than I do
no that's a lie that was a lie secretly
lies more than me do you think that you
are our parents favorite child no we all
know my older brother is who is your
best friend you are
true ah that's gonna make mom cry for
sure do you think I pulled off red hair
in college yeah but you had two shades
of red hair one we didn't do as well on
uh-huh I think we got around to like
this second shade of red hair then I
felt better about it likely you've lived
with me for over three decades of your
life would you say that's too much
yes true this two and nine and a half
months before that nine months before
that yeah well you still owe me rent
do you still blame me from when I broke
your phone in school when my phone rings
Oh uh-huh
have you ever blamed anything on me no
that's a lie a hundred percent a lie
I'm really relieved it's over I'm sure
John can tell you I'm feeling a lot
better now Karen asked some questions I
am not thrilled about it's gonna be no
holds barred since you think that your
questions are gonna be better than mine
no I those are really good it's saying
it yeah those are really good I worked
hard on this is how man it's hard
realizing that I'm the dumb
[Music]
never saw you right now I'm actually
feeling kind of okay now you're fine
I just wrote these five minutes of code
so they're gonna be you wrote them back
when you were my age come on now we're
just gonna go right for the jugular have
you ever been sexually attracted to one
of my girlfriends no that's a lie
which one all of them no did you like my
previous boyfriend which one you know
which one you can't stare this out of me
how long do you have to wait before look
my detector can't tell did you like my
previous boyfriend no that's true I'm
trying to be honest I think you could
have done better it's nice to me yeah
have you ever told one of our parents
you or me to get out of trouble yes who
have you ever kept a secret from me no
that's a lie okay like one fine I ate
the ice cream from that container that
one time yes
are you the evil twin no that's this
thing's broken
do you like all of my friends my
separate friends yes I was like all your
friends now but I was thinking of one in
college that I didn't okay no that's
fair enough
do you think you're more attractive than
me yes yeah well you some conceited
dudes I am we're pretty full of
ourselves much more of a liar than I
thought I was I can't believe you asked
me if you were my best friend I just
wanted it on record I feel like people
are gonna watch that and be like Oh
honesty is the best policy we have a
really great relationship where we can
tell each other anything so I was gonna
be super shocked I hope it's the last
lie detector I thought I need to take
yeah this was probably the best
circumstances to be hooked up to a lie
detector test just ask silly questions -
your twin brother we have a strong
trusting foundation that being said I
can't believe some of the stuff you said
I will never forgive you and that
[Music]